et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
françois-xavier bellamy bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous des
robes de bal républicain on est ensemble
pendant 20 min pour un interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour fabrice vce à redon
bonjour auriol du retour
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france et on commence bien sûr avec
l'actualité des républicains et des
régionales jean castex a donc annoncé
hier le retrait de la liste de la
république en marche en région sud
provence alpes côte d'azur et la
majorité présidentielle se rallie donc à
renaud muselier le président l'est
républicain sortant de la région
candidat à sa succession
françois-xavier bellamy est ce que cette
alliance est l'illustration que
désormais il y a dans votre parti de
droite irréconciliables non je ne crois
pas et d'ailleurs la meilleure preuve
c'est que en réalité je sais que dans le
parti très peu suivront kono muselier il
a été désavoué immédiatement et j'en
suis très heureux par christian jacob le
président du parti d hier parce qu'au
fond nous sommes tous conscients et si
nous sommes restés à droite c'est parce
que nous savons que les français ont
besoin de clarté et de transparence
emmanuel macron prétendait apporter le
nouveau monde et nous nous retrouvons
devant le pire de ce qui ressemble à
l'effondrement à la au délitement de la
quatrième république dans des manoeuvres
d'appareil qui ne peuvent qu est que ray
les français de toutes parts d'ailleurs
sophie plus elle n'avait pas de mots
assez durs pour critiquer renaud
muselier il ya encore quelques jours et
maintenant elle le rejoint
le premier ministre de la france on se
demande bien pourquoi prend l'initiative
d'annoncer lui-même cette alliance de
circonstance qui n'a en réalité aucune
signification
et moi je ne comprends pas je le dis
très simplement je ne comprends pas le
choix qui est fait aujourd'hui par
renaud muselier qui il ya quelques jours
encore sur les antennes de vos confrères
de bfm tv expliqué que cela n'arriverait
pas et qu'il n'y aurait pas une liste
commune de la république en marché des
républicains est ce qu on sait la côte
est ce que c'est la peur de perdre qui a
pu faire bouger les lignes au temps du
côté de renommée shaïek de sophie cluzel
et c'est exactement cela qui de toute
façon finira par créer la défaite frère
de politiques ont rapporté ses propos de
thierry mariani qui disait
le concurrent du rassemblement national
si j'avais dû écrire le scénario moi
même je n'aurais pas pu imaginer mieux
mais je crois qu'en effet tous ces jeux
d'appareil ne peuvent qu écoeuré les
électeurs ne peuvent que les révoltés et
on a envie de dire vous en paraphrasant
de churchill vous avez voulu éviter la
défaite au prix du déshonneur vous avez
le déshonneur et vous aurez la défaite
que représente la république en marche
en réalité c'est d'abord un gigantesque
aveu de faiblesse de la part du
président de la république d'ailleurs
qui n'a pas su créer un véritable
mouvement
il a beau avoir tous les leviers il a
fallu qu'il passe par ce type de
manoeuvre pour pouvoir espérer avoir une
place dans une élection régionale qu'il
aura tout fait pour repousser pour ne
pas garantir pour ne pas à faire la
preuve de sa de sa fragilité en france
et auprès des français tout cela est
tout cela est dérisoire tout cela abîme
profond juste concrètement pour qu'on
comprenne votre pensée ça veut dire
qu'en faisant ça renaud julie fait le
jeu du rassemblement national c'est ça
en tous les cas je ne vois pas comment
il peut susciter l'envié la conviction
comment il peut susciter la confiance
mais c'est la même chose de la
république en marche et j'ai envie de
dire d'une certaine manière que c'est la
même chose du rassemblement national
regardez dans cette élection moi je
serais un électeur du sud
je serait effondré vous avez le choix
entre d'un côté une liste de bric et de
broc fait avec des gens qui se critiquer
hier entre la république en marché une
liste anciennement investi par les
républicains de l'autre côté vous avez
monsieur mariani qui lui a fait toute sa
carrière à l'ump puis aux républicains
avant de les quitter il avait dit tout
le mal qu'ils pensaient pendant des
années du front national et maintenant
le voilà candidat du front national
tout ça parce qu'il a opportunément
trouver une place sur une liste aux
européennes il ya deux ans il quitte le
parlement européen deux ans après son
élection parce que une autre place se
présentent à la tête de la région
mais c'est dramatique en scène
dramatique et moi j'ai juste envie de
dire que on a besoin pour l'avenir de
notre pays c'est pas seulement pour
l'avenir de la droite c'est pas
seulement pour l'avenir de nos partis
les partis ne compte pas on a besoin
pour l'avenir de nos pays de retrouver
des élus qui est un peu plus de
constance un peu plus de clarté et
qu'ils puissent de nouveau susciter la
confiance ce n'est pas avec ces
manoeuvres laconi par les registres
parler du choix du coup qu'ont les
électeurs de la région suit est ce que
vous allez leur offrir un autre chose qu
il y aura une liste des républicains
dans ces élections on va en discuter
dans les dents les dans les heures qui
viennent dans les jours qui viennent on
a une réunion importante demain en tous
les cas ce qui est certain mais vous
c'est que la liste souhaité ni c'est que
c'est que cette liste portée par la
république en marche n'est pas né plus
ne sera pas soutenue par les
républicains elle ne peut pas l'être et
elle ne le sera pas et j'en suis très
heureux et maintenant au fond le grand
le grand le grand problème et il faut
bien le dire le mauvais coup qui est
fait à la démocratie parce que c'en est
un c'est que cette manoeuvre intervient
à quelques jours du dépôt des listes
donc il faut que les citoyens se rendent
compte de la difficulté dans laquelle
les républicains sont mis parce que
constitue une liste à l'élection
régionale c'est un travail difficile
surtout quand on veut rassembler des
compétences des gens qui représentent
tous les départements d'une région 105
ces personnes
c'est évidemment très compliqué à faire
mais si le défi peut être relevé je
crois qu'il le faut parce que nous le
devons encore une fois à la transparence
et à la liste estampillée les
républicains dans la région
françois-xavier bellamy vous le disiez à
l'instant jean castex qui est un homme
qui vient de chez vous terry thierry
mariani a reçu mandat
il vient de chez vous renaud muselier
s'allient donc république à salim est ce
que à la fois en tant qu homme politique
et philosophe doit-on le rappeler
vous êtes inquiet pour la droite est-ce
que parfois vous vous dites la droite en
france est en train de disparaître
moi je suis pas inquiet pour la droite
parce que la droite finalement ça ne
compte pas à ce qui compte c'est la
france et si je me suis engagé à droite
c'est parce que je crois que la droite a
les solutions dans la france a besoin
pour reconstruire son avenir et ce qui
me frappe c'est que vous avez raison de
le dire au fond toutes les familles
politiques qui sont en train de
prospérer sur la crise démocratique
française le fond en essayant de tuer
cette famille politique qu'est la droite
ce qui est bien le signe qu'elle a sans
doute quelque chose à dire à notre
avenir puisque si marine le pen tente de
se saisir de ce créneau en allant
chercher nos propres cadres
la république en marche tente elle aussi
de s'engager sur ce créneau alors que
emmanuel macron rappelons le quand même
vient du parti socialiste qu'il a fait
tout le début de sa carrière comme l'un
des cadres principaux puis l'un des
ministres importants de françois
hollande si aujourd'hui il vient chasser
sur les terres de la droite pour parler
le langage politicien c'est parce qu'il
sait que la france aspire à ce que la
droite a à dire de l'avenir de la france
les français ont besoin d'ordre et c'est
peut-être de ça qu'il faudrait d'abord
parler ils ont besoin de sécurité
ils ont besoin de pouvoir retrouver
confiance dans une économie prospère
ils ont besoin de pouvoir retrouver un
système éducatif qui fonctionne pour
l'avenir de leurs enfants
tous ces sujets là sont majeurs sur tous
ces sujets je suis convaincu que les
intuitions qui sont celles de notre
famille politique et surtout que les
convictions que notre famille politique
aurait toujours dû continuer de défendre
avec la même clarté la même constance et
qu'elle devrait pouvoir défendre à la
prochaine élection présidentielle sont
majoritaires en france et c'est la
raison pour laquelle emmanuel macron a
besoin de se saisir de l'électorat de
droite comme marine le pen a besoin de
se saisir de l'électorat de droite
mais ces manoeuvres politiciennes elles
le font que détruire le débat
démocratique et la transparence du débat
démocratique et on aurait envie de dire
à mâcon il a dit ressaisir de sas que
c'est pas la preuve de la faiblesse de
votre parti s'est lassé vos idées mais
de vata c'est en tous les cas ce qui
crée la faiblesse de notre partie gelée
vécu pendant l'élection européenne très
directement le seul but d' emmanuel
macron c'est et de détruire les
républicains emmanuel macron ça lui va
très bien que marine le pen prospère ça
lui va très bien parce que ce qu'il veut
c'est mettre en scène cette espèce
d'éternel front républicain
ce deuxième tour de la présidentielle
rejouer en permanence qui en fait ashiq
si notre vie démocratique parce que ça
prive les français de toute alternance
authentique au lieu d'avoir un vrai
débat sur l'avenir
on espère on essaye de mettre en scène
un combat absurde entre populisme et
progressisme qui ne veut rien dire pour
les français et qui ne porte aucune
espèce d'espoir et c'est ça qu'il
faudrait réussir à redonner et donc moi
je moi je me battrai en tous les cas je
me battrai pour que la fidélité puisse
finir par payer pour que la fidélité
soit le socle sur lequel les français
pourront retrouver confiance et je crois
que nous sommes nombreux
je ne suis pas le seul à penser que ces
manoeuvres la n'honore pas ceux qui les
pratiquent et surtout qu'elles
desservent profondément le débat
démocratique et j'aurais envie de dire
pour terminer que dans la politique je
crois que tout n'est pas à faire
d'opportunisme la seule question qui
compte n'est même pas de gagner une
élection
ce qui compte le plus c'est de
contribuer à la vie de son pays à la
liberté des français en servant
justement la clarté du débat
démocratique et j'ai honte moi j'ai
honte
typiquement pour sophie cluzel je
n'aimerais pas être à sa place encore
une fois je relisais ce matin en venant
ce qu'elle disait de renaud muselier
il y encore quelques jours comment
peut-on se regarder dans une glace
quand on retourne sa veste ne serait ce
que pour gagner une élection mais tout
ça est tellement médiocre quand bien
même tout cela finirait par être payant
dans les urnes
je crois que malheureusement c'est la
france qui sera perdante parce que on ne
pourra pas s'étonner ensuite que
l'abstention progress et quand bien même
ce serait payant dans les urnes je
n'envie pas ceux qui gagneront avec des
stratégies comme celle là on va
continuer à parler des régionales parce
qu'elles disent peut-être beaucoup de la
ligne de votre parti
renaud muselier qui fait donc alliance
avec la république en marche dans les
deux heures il perd l'investiture des
républicains gilles platret en bourgogne
franche comté mais il s'allie avec des
membres de debout la france et on y
maintient le républicain lui
maintiennent son investiture
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui pour les
républicains c'est plus grave de
s'allier à emmanuel macron cas nicolas
dupont aignan en tous les cas il n'y a
pas la même portée vous en conviendrez
avec moi
la république en marche c'est le parti
qui exerce aujourd'hui le le pouvoir qui
a tous les leviers institutionnels qui a
la majorité à l'assemblée nationale qui
est au gouvernement
donc évidemment si les républicains sont
en parti d'opposition et je crois qu'ils
le sont et je crois qu'ils doivent
l'être
ça a un sens très singulier de prétendre
s'allier avec la majorité
et ça ne vous aura pas échappé le fait
que le premier ministre en personne
aille dans le journal du dimanche
annoncé cet accord d'appareils en tous
les cas cet accord pardonnez moi il n'y
a pas d'accord d'appareil puisque les
républicains n'ont évidemment pas
souscrit à cette attente maire de lys
temps qu'il aille annoncé cette fusion
de listes c'est le signe que cette
décision a une portée autrement plus
importantes
mais ça veut dire quoi donc gilles
platret ça ne vous pose pas de problème
qu'il est l'investiture des républicains
alors qu'il va avoir sur sa liste des
membres de debout la france
mais le sujet encore une fois n'est pas
du tout le même après pour le reste il
ya des questions de de l'ess que c'est
pas révélateur quand même d'une certaine
ligne quand eric ciotti cette semaine
dans valeurs actuelles il dit ce qui
nous différencie du rassemblement
national c'est notre capacité à
gouverner pour vous d axa qui vous
différencie aujourd'hui du rassemblement
national à berne et je crois qu'on a
fait dire à eric ciotti ce qu'il n'avait
pas dit ce qui est certain et pour le
coup je le constate tous les jours au
parlement européen c'est que le
rassemblement national n'est pas
crédible pour gouverner
et encore une fois c'est la raison pour
laquelle emmanuel macron mis sur marine
le pen parce qu'il sait parfaitement
qu'à la fin c'est celle qui a le plus de
chance de le faire rire
aujourd'hui marine le pen est
fondamentalement la première alliés des
manuels macron et c'est comme ça qu'il
la traite il a besoin d'elle parce qu'il
sait très bien que face à n'importe quel
candidat de droite au deuxième tour
emmanuel macron perd l'élection
présidentielle face à marine le pen
probablement il la gagne moi je crois
qu'il l'a guère les républicains
même titre qu emmanuel macron de marine
le pen
encore une fois mon sentiment c'est
qu'on joue le petit théâtre de
l'antifascisme reprendre l'expression de
lionel jospin alors qu'en réalité tout
le monde a sous les yeux le fait que
marine le pen ne gagnera pas il suffit
de se souvenir de ce débat de 2017 que
s'est il passé depuis
sur quel sujet s'est elle formée sur
quels points est elle devenue d'une
compétence incontournable quelles sont
les idées que le rassemblement national
à pousser en avant qui permettrait de
considérer qu'il est devenu crédible je
suis le premier à le déplorer
je vois que la france est pris est pris
au piège de cette malédiction
démocratique que représente un combat de
sourds qui n'est pas un débat politique
et donc je crois que eric ciotti toucher
du doigt est quelque chose qui est
parfaitement clair c'est que en réalité
le rassemblement national est un parti
structurellement de protestation et
d'opposition qui ne peut pas prétendre
constituer une alternative démocratique
authentique que vous le considérez au
même titre qu emmanuel macron quand
guillaume pelletier qu'est votre numéro
deux il dit qu'il votera blanc si un
duel entre emmanuel macron et maryse aux
fans comme il est est ce que pour vous
c'est pareil est ce qu'aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron égale marines up mais
non c'est pas du tout paris ils n'ont
pas du tout la même fonction dans le
spectre démocratique emmanuel macron
c'est le système qui veut se maintenir
au pouvoir et marine le pen c'est celle
qui permettra à emmanuel macron se
maintenir au pouvoir ce que j'essaye de
vous dire c'est justement que c'est
dramatique qu'on en soit déjà à se
prononcer sur la question de savoir
c'est l'argument de la choisir au
deuxième tour la présidentielle entend
bien ces régionales c'est un peu la
répétition de la présidentielle et si on
vous écoute bien ça veut dire un
candidat pour la droite
lequel et quand le désigner je je je
crois qu'il faut en tous les cas elle
c'était très important que la droite
soit très clair dès l'annoncé surprise
de ceux de ce ralliement qui n'avait pas
été concertés et d'ailleurs redisons-le
dans les jours qui précèdent cette
décision il ya eu des échanges nombreux
entre renaud muselier lui-même christian
estrosi
et puis les instances de notre famille
politique christian jacob le président
du parti et à aucun moment semble-t-il
cette annonce n'a été partagé avant
qu'elle soit annoncée par la presse donc
maintenant nous sommes au pied du mur je
le disais tout à l'heure je crois que
dans la mesure du possible il faudrait
faire une liste et si les élections
régionales sont une répétition
l'élection présidentielle alors
regardons toutes les régions dans
lesquelles la république en marche n'a
aucune chance de gagner et considère
d'ailleurs que en provence alpes côte
d'azur
cette alliance inattendue n'est rien
d'autre que le signe de la faiblesse
évidente du parti des manuels mâcon qui
ne peut pas constituer par lui-même et
une perspective nationale une
perspective pardon une perspective
régionale
donc si ça devait être une répétition de
la présidentielle ça voudrait dire et ça
pour le coup j'en suis convaincu que
c'est sur notre famille politique que
pèse la responsabilité de représenter de
vous présenter cette alternative à
laquelle les français ont droit à un
dernier mot là-dessus françoise david
bellamy après on parle de la crise
sanitaire à ce qu'aujourd'hui renaud
muselier il a encore sa place aux
républicains pour vous est ce que vous
vous demander son exclusion
je pense que defacto il se met à l'écart
des républicains en conduisant une liste
qui ne sera pas soutenue par notre
famille politique pour les régionales
oui mais est-ce qu'il peut encore garder
sa carte au parti mais ce serait aussi
minime cela dit il faut l'exclure moment
pour le coup j'ai le plus grand respect
pour les personnes chacun fait ses choix
mais si renaud muselier souhaitent
conduire une liste soutenue par la
république en marche il me semble qu'il
est parfaitement logique qu'ils
rejoignent la république en marche et je
pense qu'on a besoin de ses fins il ya
un trait il ya un très grand nombre
d'élus qui peut-être préféreront se dire
que pour reprendre le schéma que vous
proposiez tout à l'heure il préfère
aller à la république en marche mais
elles préfèrent aller dans d'autres
familles politiques
au moins qu'ils le fassent et les choses
seront plus claires oui aujourd'hui
c'est la première étape
prenez le 3 mai première étape des 4
étapes annoncées par le président de la
république la semaine dernière votre du
poste du pass sanitaire largement
adoptée par le parlement vous avez voté
contre alors moi je m'en étais expliqué
d'ailleurs sur votre plateau il ya un
moment j'ai une vraie réserve sur le sur
le certificat vert parce que c'est comme
cela qu'il est présenté
par la commission européenne à bruxelles
je conçois parfaitement qu'il soit
nécessaire d'abord d'avoir une stratégie
vaccinale pour faire reculer cette
épidémie je n'ai pas du tout de défiance
à l'égard de la vaccination d'une
manière générale qui est l'un des
miracles par lesquels la science nous à
nous a préservés de bien des des
maladies extrêmement grave pour
l'humanité
je conçois aussi qu'il est parfaitement
nécessaire d'harmoniser la
reconnaissance des vaccins pour qu'on se
retrouve pas avec une diversité de
dispositifs ou de certificats on a
suffisamment souffert de la cacophonie
européenne dans la crise pour ne pas
chercher à la résoudre
ce qui m'inquiète plus c'est la mention
non pas d'un passeport vaccinale c'est à
dire quelque chose qui puisse permettre
d'aller d'un pays à l'autre mais d'un
certificat vert c'est-à-dire un
certificat qui demain devrait de manière
explicite c'est ainsi qu'il est présenté
par la commission pouvoir conditionner
l'accès à des lieux publics à des
événements publics à des établissements
recevant du public des restaurants des
musées des théâtres
au fond cette idée que pour la première
fois on pourrait conditionner l'entrée
dans un espace public à la ou même dans
un espace privé dans une entreprise par
exemple dans un commerce
on pourrait conditionner l'accès à un
lieu à la délivrance d'un certificat
vaccinale ou bien d'un autre d'une autre
condition médicale quelle qu'elle soit
et ça pour le coup c'est tout à fait
inédit et je crois qu'il est d'abord ça
me paraît à la fois avec les
connaissances que j'ai sanitairement
absurde d'un point de vue
épidémiologique ça n'a pas beaucoup de
sens parce que l'effet attendu d'un
vaccin c'est d'abord un effet collectif
ce qui compte le plus
ça n'est pas que individuellement vous
ayez été vaccinées mais c'est qu'on
arrive à un niveau de vaccination qui
fait que le virus ne peut plus circuler
donc le sujet n'est n'est pas de
conditionner l'accès à des lieux
particuliers pour des individus mais de
faire en sorte qu'on puisse avoir une
stratégie efficace et de ce point de vue
là le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
la situation française ne brille pas par
sa part son efficacité il ya aussi
quelque chose de tout à fait paradoxale
à dire qu'on va potentiellement vous
interdire d'accéder à des lieux ou à des
événements alors que vous n'avez tout
simplement pas pu avoir accès au vaccin
parce qu'on n'était pas assez bien
organisé pour ça et deuxièmement ça me
paraît un vrai problème en termes
démocratique en termes de libertés
publiques
je pense qu'on est dans un moment très
particulier de notre histoire
il faut qu'on arrive à faire la preuve
que nos démocraties sont capables de
faire face à une crise sans renoncer à
elle même on est devant des modèles
alternatifs celui de la chine en
particulier qui sont des modèles d'hyper
contrôle des modèles d'hyper régulation
des modèles qui méprisent complètement
les libertés publiques et qui font
aujourd'hui une sorte de démonstration
de leur efficacité supérieure à celle
des démocraties
moi je dis que nous avons aujourd'hui le
devoir c'est une responsabilité majeure
de faire la preuve qu'il est possible de
faire face à une crise sans renoncer à
nos libertés fondamentales et refaire
confiance en français ça veut dire
individuellement ça veut dire gagner en
efficacité et de ce point de vue là il
faut évidemment et c'est la première
chose à faire que l'état soit capable de
se remettre en cause parce que nous
avons échoué sur les masques nous avons
échoué sur les tests nous avons échoué
sur la stratégie de tester des pistes et
isolés nous avons nous sommes en train
de prendre toujours du retard sur la
vaccination même si ce retard se
rattrape c'est bien le signe que nos
démocraties doivent s'interroger sur
leur efficacité mais on peut gagner en
efficacité sans renoncer à nos libertés
et c'est la démonstration fondamental
que nous avons à faire aujourd'hui
un mot sur une autre actualité de
l'europe c'est les eurodéputés qui ont
refusé d'approuver le budget de frontex
celle agence européenne des
gardes-frontière des garde-côtes frontex
qui est soupçonné d'avoir participé à
des renvois forcés de migrants
alors ça n'entrave pas forcément
l'action de lagence ce vote des députés
mais c'est quand même un signal
politique envoyé pour vous c'est un très
mauvais signal politique avec toute
notre délégation lr parlement européen
nous avons voté pour accorder la
décharge budgétaire à frontex d'abord
parce que les arguments qui étaient
employées contre frontex n'avait rien à
voir avec le budget je trouve que c'est
très malhonnête de refuser de voter une
décharge budgétaire quand on n'a pas de
reproche à faire à une agence pour son
exécution budgétaire
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que au
fond qu'est ce qui est reproché à
frontex
ce qui est reproché à frontex c'est
d'avoir refoulé des migrants hors des
frontières de l'union européenne
pour le dire autrement on reproche à une
agence de garde-côtes et deux garde
frontières d'avoir fait son travail
celui qui consiste à éviter que l'union
européenne ne subisse une immigration
illégale
il y a des
hier cette manoeuvre la stratégie
désespérée de gens qui cherchent à miner
de l'intérieur toute politique
européenne ferme et solide face à
l'immigration illégale
or on le sait l'un des défis majeurs
pour la survie de l'europe c'est sa
capacité à maîtriser nos frontières
extérieures communes
c'est fondamental et de ce point de vue
là il est vrai que depuis quelques mois
on assiste à une montée en puissance de
l'agencé frontex qui voit son budget
augmenter qui voit ses effectifs se
développer et qui grâce au travail de
son directeur fabrice l'algérie est en
train de devenir de plus en plus
efficace pour éviter c'est ses entrées
illégales de migrants j'observe
d'ailleurs soit dit en passant vous
demandiez tout à l'heure ce qui nous
oppose rassemblement national j'observe
que cette politique
objectivement efficace et qui d'ailleurs
est aujourd'hui soutenu par le
rassemblement national a fait l'objet d'
attaques précises et permanente de la
part du rassemblement national qui a
voté des amendements qui a déposé des
amendements pour baisser le budget
frontex pour empêcher cette montée en
puissance russe très heureux de voir
qu'aujourd'hui par opportunisme
il se rallie à ce qu'ils critiquent haïr
mais vous voyez que c'est quelque chose
qui nous distingue nous nous cherchons à
apporter des solutions aux problèmes et
la question des migrations illégales est
un problème existentiel pour l'europe et
donc frontex doit pouvoir effectivement
nous permettre de maîtriser nos
frontières le mauvais procès qui est
fait aujourd'hui à cette agence est que
nous avons dénoncé depuis des semaines
nous avons écrit avec toutes nos
délégations une lettre ouverte à la
commissaire joensson qui attaqué
durement frontex ce mauvais procès que
nous n'avons cessé de dénoncer
il est en réalité un sujet crucial parce
qu'il montre que certains veulent
absolument que l'europe n'est pas de
frontières et qu'elle ne puisse pas les
protéger un dernier mot fabrice sur une
autre actualité c'est sa tribune des
militaires oui ce délitement que dénonce
ces militaires dans cette tribune que
vous avez certainement lu qui a été
longuement commenté
vous le partagez il partager cette idée
qui à un délitement qui est en train de
s'opérer en france bien sûr
comment ne pas le voir comment ne pas le
nommer la vérité c'est que nous voyons
bien qu'aujourd'hui l'ordre de la
république et défier partout sur le
territoire français nous voyons bien
qu'aujourd'hui nos forces de l'ordre
malgré leur engagement exceptionnel non
plus les moyens de garantir la sécurité
des français
nous voyons que la question de
l'islamisme n'est absolument pas résolu
et que les fractures françaises ne
cessent de s'augmenter et sur toutes ces
questions là évidemment il faut poser un
diagnostic lucide sinon on n'a aucune
chance d'en sortir de l'action pour ses
généraux notamment parce que je crois
c'est que là encore on revient sur la
question du rassemblement national ce
qui était irresponsable et absurde c'est
que marine le pen ait tenté
d'instrumentaliser la parole de ses
officiers et qu'elle et cherchait
justement et qu'elle les ait mis en
difficulté en cherchant à récupérer
leurs paroles qui aurait dû être
respecté en tant que tel mais pour le
reste
moi je suis fascinée de la réaction du
gouvernement et autant le dire je suis
même un peu révolté
on est face à des menaces gigantesque et
tout ce que le gouvernement trouve à
faire pour attirer l'attention
tout ce sur quoi le gouvernement
voudrait se mobiliser ce sont des gens
qui ont servi la france toute leur vie
et qui se permet de décrire qu'il trouve
que la situation est critique
vous êtes d'accord sur le fond on a bien
compris vous êtes aussi d'accord sur la
forme et sur la méthode donc former une
question d'autorité pour le gouvernement
vous l'entendez j'imagine non je ne le
comprends pas aujourd'hui évidemment il
y a de la part de la de la force
militaire
un devoir d'impartialité sur le plan
proprement politique ça ne retire pas à
des militaires en particulier à des
militaires à la retraite qui sont
sorties du service actif
ça ne leur retire pas je crois le droit
de dire ce qu'ils ont sous les yeux et
ce qu'il croit être bon pour l'avenir de
leur pays
encore une fois il me semble que dans la
tribune que j'ai lu il n'y avait pas
d'appel à l'insurrection militaire il
n'y avait pas d'appel au putsch et quand
je vois mais c'est sidérant d'ailleurs
de la part d'autres forces politiques
jean luc mélenchon qui n'a trouvé à fait
arc un misérable tweets sur le meurtre
d'une policière à rambouillet par un
terroriste islamiste qui n'a pas réussi
à dire qu'elle était policière et qui
n'a pas réussi à dire qu'il était
islamistes et qui fait des dizaines de
messages pour s'étonner pour s'émouvoir
pour alerter sur le fait que le danger
qui menace la france ce serait quelques
militaires à la retraite qui ose dire
l'inquiétude qu'ils ont pour l'avenir de
leur pays
je me dis que malheureusement notre
classe politique le gouvernement y
compris a du mal avec le sens des
proportions et a sans doute du mal à
nommer la menace là où elle se trouve
vraiment et merci beaucoup merci
françois xavier merci avons arrêté notre
invité ce matin merci fabrice ont
regardé une du dauphiné libéré c'est le
procès le landais qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui pour le meurtre d'arthur
noyer le landais va-t-il s'expliquer
c'est à la une du dauphiné libéré merci
beaucoup
[Musique]